thanks for audience for coming last day
of the whole workshop but know that the
whole workshop but the first week of the
workshop so my name is Eli and today I'm
gonna talk about lettuce multilinear
maps of schism and the possibility
beyond and it's a great honor for
talking about all the topics we are most
of the actually the inventor of these
techniques are here so first ascent is
its inventors and then the organizers
and so let's get started so okay so what
are multi linear maps so multi linear
maps so to talk about your multilinear
maps in cryptography let me first start
from the classical discrete log problem
in cryptography so the discrete log
problem says ask so if I give you a
generator G and tree to the S for some
secrets mark you could refine G and if
you contact finding it's hard then
because the first is a show how to do
key exchange and then they say how to do
public encryption from this simple
looking problem and so so after that we
start thinking about how to do something
called pioneer pairing so which looks
like the following structure so if you
have the discrete log sample in to sort
of source groups and there's a magic way
of computing the product of the exponent
in what I denoted as the target group so
this is called a pairing operation so
you can think about the goal of this
mapping is to still hide secrets s 1 and
s 2 in the exponents
at the same time you are able to compute
G to the sys - in the target group and
the way of showing how to compute Ave
pairing in the Bittaker group was a date
back to 1986 and after many years people
find a real crypto applications of it
including the last one which is attended
by ski exchange so
so can we talk if we didn't stop at
bilinear maps and the one of the author
of the bilinear map paper burn a and
together with a disturber burg they ask
so what if we have a more general way of
doing mapping code multilinear maps so
if we have a lot of source group maybe
they are the same maybe they are
different and in each of the group let's
assume discrete log problem is hard and
still we have a magical way of computing
the product of the order secrets in the
exponent so the sort of thing about the
go as DISA critical the functional it
ago is what I defined and think about
the security go as hiding all the
exponents in the source group and also
in the target group is if it's not 0 so
also they didn't find a concrete
instantiation of this multi linear map
Beaune and Silverberg propose that if we
have such a map then there's a lot of
cryptographic applications including a
tree being unique signatures rockets
encryption etc etc so for these three
types of work the first work has already
win the Turing award the the Bedini map
applications has wind a coda price and
the third award we are wait to see and I
can say at least at this moment this
paper has already win the best paper
award in my mind and then let me tell
you why so in this paper
Oh haven't been to the that's one yet
don't worry
so it's just a pony Superbook so so also
in the as I said in this paper they
didn't mention any concrete
instantiation but in these papers they
explore a lot of attempts of
constructing such a man and so here are
two like quotes from the paper so first
as I say if an M motolinia map is
computable it's reasonable to expect it
to come from geometry as the case for
Ray and Tate pairing we're a question
too and then the paper lists a lot of
attempts of searching for such a
generalization in high degree s quite
high degree generalization of 8-bit
curves and this is a sinking in Section
seven point six seven point four or
something like that they say after many
attempts if meant and multilinear maps
cannot be found for n bigger than too
low could at least hope for such a map
to come arise from motives so three
motives is actually a double it has two
meanings so when it's like first you are
motivated by looking for such a map
because of this it's curve cryptography
applications in the other on the other
side motive is also a mathematical term
being arbitrary geometry so at the first
time I read this paper I think I spend a
half of the day looking for Wikipedia to
try to understand what is a motive and
then I asked a lot of friends in the
math department and as they trying to
convince me don't look don't spend too
much time understanding what it is and
but at least we can say you know it
gives us a lot of imagination and even
so even the original paper of boundary
Berger didn't find such a map there's a
reason to propose about one of computing
trainee Nia maps from a billion
varieties so this one I think right now
the status is it still requires for the
investigations
okay so the focus of today is lattices
and this is a lattice workshop and if
I'm keeping talking about the motive
maybe the organizer will be happy
so why firm lattices so so after the
original proposal of motive of looking
for motive looking for multi linear Maps
motivated in the paper of boney
Silverberg the first candidate
instantiation of such a map actually
found come from lattice it's a
breakthrough at 2013 by card entry
halevi so why do we think about this
looks like lattice related candidate
because this is a actually candidate
based on a variant of the entry problem
let me just clarify here by a variant of
the entry problem I mean like the
instantiation of the or the intuition of
the harness come from a variant of the
entry problem so the actually security
whatever you want to prove cannot be but
based on whatever variances they have
proposed so no security reduction to any
concrete assumption is given and the
paper is also beautiful it lists a lot
of cryptanalysis attempts of break-ins
ER candidates to be honest I also watch
the video of the other previous latest
talks and during the workshop and I
think at least you can learn half of the
material from the previous talk about
just to reading this paper section 7 for
section 6 maybe I remember
so after the first account also so I
also want to say something about so this
paper actually gives a new way of
thinking about multi linear maps so the
previous way we think about multi linear
maps as a generalization of bilinear
maps so you have low source group you
have source group versus group two you
have the secrets hiding in the exponent
you try to compute it and it will go to
the target group so this work gives a
new way of thinking about multi linear
map you can think about it as
homomorphic encryption plus publicly
zero test functionality so homomorphic
encryption like the idea the idea of
version of it allows you to compute
compute that I encrypted the data on and
in the end it's still encrypted you need
the secret to do to be able to decrypt
and the motolinia map allows you to have
additional public zero test the
functionality so that you can test
whether in the end you get an encryption
of 0 or encryption of nonzero at least
let's think about it in this way so and
then so su route maybe the first half of
adages talk you can think about the
motolinia map I'm not talking about
today the security go is you can think
about the minimum goal and you can think
about it the best ago the minimum goal
is to hide the exponent in the whatever
way you compute until the last one you
can test whether it's zero on random and
the maximum go is like the only thing
you can do is to evaluate in the test
you can not allow any partial
information
and after this work there's two other
proposal of motolinia map candidates
actually each of them start from I think
it's fair to say they are starting from
one of the the previous lattice based
for the homomorphic encryption scheme
the one of which were CRT thirteen it's
based on a variant of the approximately
problem and as we heard from yesterday
this the best algorithm to solve it is a
lattice algorithm and the last candidate
from digit 15 is another candidate
inspired by the photo homomorphic
encryption scheme from g SW 13 so so so
so really what so so so far I have told
you like we have three candidates
multilinear maps from lattice theory and
their candidate and all the papers
mention how do you do correctness and
they provide you what's the intuitive
way of achieve security and what really
gives multilinear maps a pound is what
can you do more than what is originally
suggesting the bone a superbug paper so
in fact this is only the partial picture
of what you can do from motolinia map
instead which is explored after 2013 and
in the center of the picture I believe
it is this line so how to construct a
indistinguishability obfuscation from
multi linear maps
so I
so so yeah so we need to assume
additional assumption like this gridlock
is hard and the music this is a work by
will have the cheese you see there
so I hear like all the arrow means like
adding or than normal assumption you can
make and that's crazy a presumption okay
this is the repetition so I think in the
center of the picture is like the
connection of multi linear map implies
indistinguishability obfuscation and
then indistinguishability obfuscation
implies everything so let me say more
words about indistinguishability
obfuscation here so indistinguishability
office kitchen is a notion of office
kitchen defined by the work of berger go
get a provocateur so what is the program
of sketcher so you take a clear test
program you try to compare it and make
it office created program so that no one
can understand what's going on
besides the input-output functionality
and we wanted to crack the nice for the
obfuscation to be that whatever you
output as the obfuscated problem a
program preserve all the functionality
from the clear test program and the
secret ego is so for two programs which
has identical functionality the office
kitchen of program was a zero is
indistinguishable from the obfuscation
of program one from the other bursaries
point of view so so really this picture
should be reshaped so right now i try to
make the picture so that motolinia maps
also imply most of the stuff but really
the land of cryptography
like after two thousand six thirteen
looks like this so really it's
indistinguishability obfuscation implies
a lot of things and usually we call it a
big bow in crypto and really at the
center of take one step back so let me
pick take one step back one of my like a
personal experience so as at 2015 i come
to the summit workshop as a crypto
student i i think the first time I
really understand it right so how
powerful is cryptography it is by
reading the paper
of like indistinguishability obfuscation
implies everything especially the paper
of Sahai waters so this is a picture of
actually on the whiteboard and the third
floor I think this building in the
summer 2015
I think me together with Oksana and
other students reading the paper of
Brent constructing function encryption
from obfuscation and as you can see all
the paper at that time from obfuscation
looks like this
so you're puncturing at a lot of spots
for people who familiar birthday history
so really it's changed of the way that
we think about how to construct a
cryptographic application it's a sort of
like index in the extreme sense it tells
you that this is something that you can
do and essentially everything you can do
and I I'd also like to mention one of
application built from one of the
application beautiful
indistinguishability obfuscation without
using puncturing it's the work of
yamakawa tour that shows how to
construct a self by linear maps from
office kitchen plus something so so what
is self by linear map so previously when
I mentioned by linear map you think
about the there two source group and we
map to a target group so see of Bonnie
near map says like the target group is
the same as the source group so you are
not stopping by one mapping so if you
are mapping to the same group then it
means you can go in our in our in a gun
and all the way all the way up so so
yamakawa at all shows like how to build
a self Pinilla map from obfuscation in a
very simple way so think about you have
just any group you like to work with for
discrete log problem but right now we
are going to stuck with the RSA group so
think about you have a discrete logs and
poetry to the s and s is the secret
component so you have G to the S in
maybe the
I say group but we don't know how to
compute the exponent the the elements in
the exponent without revealing it so
here's one way to do it you have
something called a raise to s function
and then you obfuscate it so the
obfuscated functionality is exactly you
take any elements and then raise it to X
and you publish an office created a
version of this code as part of the
encoding for s so it turns out
intuitively of solutions to the hiders
and indeed yarmulke white or prove that
when n is a our modulus morally that the
oxygen has s and it becomes a self
padding and map so I hope to show this
example to you like just to show like
how powerful indistinguishable
obfuscation is and indeed there's lot to
capture if we focus on this topic so oh
please so I think the easiest answer is
like you can have like a homomorphic
encryption for run down bounded in
degree for free
strongest application I think economy
comes to the map right so think about
you if you have a Jew to the s-1 and an
obfuscation of race to s1 functionality
and you have G to the s2 and obfuscated
that race to s2 functionality so
important is that guy inside the here
and what's doubt what is T to the s1
times s2
you don't have a zero test - yeah
so so so here you can think about really
the target group is the normal the
discrete local group we are familiar
with so two to the zero is literally
missile sing with your previous replay
so you get a stupid great so you also
need to do that so I think here you can
take these two functionality and
multiply them together an off skate
outside right so so write Z as a caveat
so in theory actually the wrap-up part
becomes blow up so it's actually not in
serious not the main theory it's not a
like an unbounded but I want to say if
you have a self paneer map which even
the size doesn't grow then it's great
so great questions so let's come back to
application and let's come back to
application so I want to come back one
step before like I say surrender we have
a rough link say a lattice theory can be
a candidate to multi linear Maps and the
candidate multi linear Maps give you
candidate program obfuscation for all
the functionalities and you can ask
where are we right now so here is a
rough picture of where are we right now
so again this is the lock has selected a
picture of all the applications so and
on this picture we have a like order
applications name and the Arizer with
blue color or with orange color so with
the blue colors I think about them as
the applications inspired by multi
linear map kind of way to design
applications and right now they have a
reduction from our doubly to say if you
can break these applications you can
break our W and the rest of the
applications ran out still they have
candidates and essentially because we
still have IO candidates that's why
everyone you can start from IO to do the
one and also like someone if you
directly build it for multi linear Maps
we don't know how to break it and as
they are still very good candidate to
study and so here's there's also a
additional support that if you sink a
multi linear map it's too complicated to
analyze there's even attempts to build
in distinguishability obfuscation
without using multi linear maps I think
I will mention like some of the future
directions also related to the idea of
without using multi linear maps and
related to lattice to build i/o and so
many people are curious like so what are
the aisle candidates we have right now
so so I try to make a slide summarizing
the candidates status of all the
multilinear maps and i/o and in fact
there's already two websites
summarizing like the current status
according to their opinion and after
making this night for a week I kind of
give up so this is a slide I made
2016 at my early stage of PhD I talk
about how to build a delegation realm
computation from IO and this is the
current status at that time I think and
now is keep growing so I think the
purpose of this talk is not to make the
status complex we want to clarify what's
the current status so I hope like to
give a status report
a partial status report in the honesty
and at the end of the talk that truth
declare is the choose the clear it's the
path that I can stand to Doris but I
think at least this is to an urban
problem and so this is a summary of
urban problem left in the same as
program summer 2015 and problem number
three immittance to zero I think this
award is absolutely I need to remake my
slide then so southern dollar wants
something for the time do too alright so
this is the first of improper I remind
everybody this is not a what I invented
but yeah so so for problem to I double
check with the organizers that he
already paid
[Music]
others so some of them are not familiar
about like like so for example eight and
four I need to check with the experts I
also want to remind that actually seven
so they're still considered to be open
because we are still trying to
understand the proposal right so that's
also like a we need to go to the lawyer
to understand their what the so
plausibility that like how long does it
stay and like it was the was possible to
who right there's a lot of anger to look
at it so we need to reorder like all the
open questions like left from five years
ago anyway so the focus of today I want
to give you more insights and
explainable that his theory behind the
multi linear maps as I so essentially
like understand the the Nazi theory
behind the post digits erting and a co2
thirteen are still fascinated Obon
problems or remind you in the end but
today I will spend more time on the
candidate of digits fifteen in some
sense this is the only application sorry
this is the only multi linear map which
nowadays give us two to a few more
probable applications that inspired by
this way of designing applications and
the original paper is called graph
induced voted in a map from lattices and
let me give you before introducing digit
fifteen and let me give you two reasons
that I want to think about emphasizing
it so the first reason is what I said
like this gives a way of designing
application following almost the multi
linear map approach and with the
security reduction based on rwe and in
some sense this also creates a new
methodology of building latest
application after what we've so called a
GSW searching fh e and the BD g plus
fourteen a B
scheme that we just heard from the
previous talk so I think if you have a
way of designing application and they
see more you use the more than three
times by other paper we should consider
this as a framework and I think as these
are the two we run our frameworks we
have heard about there today and maybe
in the last few years so after seeing
that
let me start to the real business of the
play of today I have finished
introduction the overview of letters
theory to multi linear maps and for the
most of the rest of the talk I will talk
about digit 15 its functionality and a
security overview so I kind of separate
part 2 and part 3 in the following logic
so in part 2 I will try to only explain
the functionality and explain the
security intuition by small example so
this small example doesn't come a big
application and then in the the second
part of the third part of the talk I
would try to instantiate this small
examples in a large application and I
understand why it's secure what goes
wrong and the open problems will be
mentioned during the talk as you see
from the $1000 and also later we'll have
more to come
so I'll try to cover all of them before
5:00
so okay so let's get started so so
during the preparation of the talk of
this work it reminds me of like a we
read the musical notes so so I don't
know how to deliver the feeling but the
roughly needs the following so if you
read the musical scores in the early age
so for example like this one so it turns
out aside from you know which keyboard
to to press and which musical instrument
to use it doesn't give you a lot of
information about like a house of the
really play this so should we play with
this emotion or should I play with this
so I have the same feeling of reading
actually order three multi linear Maps
paper so let me tell you the feeling of
reading these three papers so first as I
tell you what they are trying to do and
then they tell you how to do achieve the
correctness first and then security is
widely open they will tell you like it
was the attempt they made and what's
that what are the attempts they have
made and why did it didn't work and you
learn a lot of stuff
so in some sense they're great papers
that they tell you how to do things
correct but how to interpret it and how
to use them it's all up to you it's like
when you see the musical score you have
your own interpretation of how to play
with it so I hope in this talk I can
deliver such a feeling like a cherry the
right pace of understanding this piece
of work also just to prepare the
audience in the original about the brief
history of the early age of digital age
15 so in the first paper in the original
work of digital 15 they provided the
functionality of the encoding and also
the equipped analytic attempts and their
candidate of multi-party exchange in IO
so what I'm going to talk about today
about both the proof intuition and the
attack intuition are coming from a few
papers mostly in the two years after the
initial publication of digital 15
and I'm involved in some of it so so
later were not mentioned the names but
really as is the talk is basically an
essence of the ideas from these papers
so also it gives you a would like to
mention like a there's also a lot of
different views and the motives of
looking at to date 15 so the original
paper of digits 15 they say you know we
we have a different way of looking at
the effigy of Gentry's the high waters
and sort of like another way of looking
at digital team is by the work of Almaty
pocket and the polar waters by showing
by motive wave by showing circular
security counter example and then they
have the need to design such a structure
that seems cancels out at Eric's plan
later so also in some of my work I have
involved you can see about digital 15 as
capturing to that is based PRF or a
generalization of the Kinane
randomization so today I will take the
simplest approach so our goal is just to
chaining your W samples so explain to
judge 15 as a way to change or W samples
so let's get started and just to remind
you of all the notations of anyways
errors so have a public matrix and then
we have a sample y equals to s times a
plus noise so think about the voice
coming from small distributions and so
consider a very similar variant so
instead of publishing one sample of a
RWE I just published sorry I shouldn't
be called one sample but I audibly
sample with one vector as the secret so
think about throughout this talk think
about the squid secret as a square
matrix and you just to choose random
random vectors in each row of the matrix
and essentially you can say this is as
hard as the iOW for one vector because
of a hybrid argument and also throughout
this talk we think about we are using yo
w with small secret again this is so to
be as hard as normally or doubly by the
by this work
the supreme head in smallness of you
need s to be small this is inherently
right for correctness because it might
apply with the ADA all right so so after
so many like a you know preparation
let's look at how do they really do the
chaining of the other be samples so in
some sense and natural analogy of think
about multi linear mapping the
latticework is the following so for the
multilinear maps in the discrete lot
language you can think about of them G
to the s1 to s2 so the natural lattice
analog is put the secret element into
the LW secret so think about right now
you have like a public a matrix and the
other B simple ways s1 where W Sampo is
s2 etc etc your double tempo was SK
Saran are great you have so many
independent samples and what we are lack
of is a way to put them together like
the way of computing the product of the
doublet secrets into the the final term
like the other with sample sorry but in
putting the product into the audibly
secret of the last sample
so how do we compute such such a map in
some sense without reviewing all the
secrets that we have in the middle so
again the idea is to use the latest
chapter that was introduced this morning
we will use native trapdoor sampling to
chain them together so again a really
freak off the functionality of ladies
trapdoor sampling so think about latest
chapter as a way of finding so if you
have a trapdoor of Y the matrix a if you
have a trapdoor then you can solve all
the SS problem using this trapdoor and
given any image Y you can find a short
premature vector D such that a times D
equals to I and the D is small and in
fact we can simple D from a discrete
Gaussian distribution
and also I want to remind you that one
where representative of a chapter is a
full rank short matrix in Z so these
think about this T is a square matrix
over the integer and it's for rank is
small and a times T equals to 0 mod Q
then T will be a chapter this is helpful
for thinking about from the attackers
point
so the real idea of Judas 15 is the
following so right now I'm trying to
explain the idea with think about MOT
linearity - we only try to take the
product of two secrets so let's think
about we prepare our W samples and the
two different a matrix is among I'm
gonna reuse one of them later we'll
reuse many of them but I ran out for the
grid - lets you reuse one of them so
right now you have two l ee samples
separately so the question is how to
connect them together so I'm gonna
connect them together using a trapdoor
sampling say I have two air W samples s
- A - B - I want to sample a pre-image
called D to earn the public matrix a 1
so have the relation any one times D 2
equals to this audibly sample and again
notice that a 1 is also the public
matrix for the products for the for that
further for the the previously order B
sample and so also just to make
everything a nice I also prepare like
premature sampling for the first example
let's say a rhino's I start from a zero
a zero doesn't have any other be simple
is it
so let's think about D 2 as the encoding
of s 2 and think about D 1 as the
encoding of s 1 so then the next
question is how do we show the
corruptness so how do we show the
functionality we want
so so to evaluate so record the goal is
to come up with something like the
product of s shows up in the secret term
of the audibly sample so what did we do
is the following
so I compute a zero times d1 times d2
and the goal is to show that this equals
to s 1 times s 2 times 8 plus some noise
and this is why it happens so let's go
slowly to this correctness issue because
this is almost the most important slice
of the talk so the most important part
is to understand the correctness exactly
define so is it like public parameters
to get keys how so later I will give
everyone name so you guys D is the
encoding a is the public parameter sort
of so right now think about only the a 0
is the public parameter and the other
these are the encoding for each of the
secret tips
so let's first to look at what's the
result of a times d1 times d2 so let's
go very slowly so you have first do a 0
times d1 this is the first order be
simple because this is a build up by the
trouble of sampling so right now we'll
try to open with the the next encoding
to become this si D + e D and notice
that E is the error term and D is the
small preimage so this this is a
relatively small we sing about it as an
oyster then let's look at the first term
and opened up again so right now really
we use the fact that the eywa is used
both as the doubly public matrix and
it's chapter is used to chain into the
next value so a1 times d2 opens up to a
s 2 times a2 plus e2 as which over here
multiplier is way outside and then let's
open this part again so right now
s 1 times s 2 times a 2 becomes sort of
the functionality we want to achieve we
want to achieve like the in the result
is the product of s times the public
matrix a 2 plus some noise so here we
use the fact that s is also coming from
small because s 1 times the error term
is also becomes a bigger error term so
after you know calculation we have the
functionality that a times D 1 times d 2
equals to sort of think about this part
as the functionality term and the rest
are all small noise so you need to set
up the modular model askew and the noise
bound so that this term is relatively
small molecule
and so in the usual Dublin terminology
as a multi linear map terminology we
think about order these are the encoding
and a is the public parameter and in
some sense you only need one proper
public parameter which is the a on the
left to start with
right
we'll come back to this equation later
on and surrender I want to also
generalize this functionality I want you
to think about a typical evaluation
pattern of digits 15 as we are trying to
encode secrets that usually we later we
can take the subset product operation so
think about there are like maybe two and
secrets we have n levels and here I
skipped a lot of a in the middle so this
is a four in the end and there are so
like a3 a2 a1 here a zero all the way to
the left
I want to encode as this secret in the
way that later I can compute the subset
product of this s times a and the
resulting encoding looks like this it
starts from a zero and have like d1 1
and D 1 0 representing each of the
secret terms exactly using this general
chaining lemma like a minus 1 times D
equals 2 si AI plus error and we were
just extended previous example of less
to to an example of lands and and here's
the example where N equals 2
again let's do the try to do the
evaluation and then like I get familiar
with what's going on
so think about I want to evaluate a
point with four bits like at 0 1 1 0 so
0 1 1 0 what just select the
corresponding matrix as the encoding
that I want to evaluate so let's say
this English example the first bit is 0
so I'll choose d-10 as the first matrix
and the second bit is 1 so I choose this
one
so by evaluating 0 1 1 0 I'm thinking
about I'm evaluating like a d-10 T 2 1 T
3 1 and the d40 so let's just open it up
again like previously to see what's the
functionality so it's really like just a
repeating the previous small example so
you first the first a chunk and then the
error pops out they put put error
together with the rest of the diene
codings they becomes the relatively big
noise and then really and actually just
open in opened again and they're really
the noise blows up and goes up so as
long as you set the modulus Q to be
relatively large so that the order
summation of the error term becomes
relatively small we still have the
correctness like the final evaluation
becomes the product of s times a and
plus small noise so I want to remind you
that actually the noise grows
exponentially with the number of levels
and it will become a problem in the
efficiency and I also want to mention
that this other boaty linear maps these
three candidates have been implemented
and actually the noise blow up is the
main reason that as they are not very
practical so I will come back to the
practical problem in the end but right
now let's sink in the asymptotic ways
that you can set the parameter so that
the noise grows relatively smaller than
in the evaluatee and you get the subset
product in the depiction on the top so
so far is let's say I give you a brief
impression of getting the functionality
of the juice 15 multi linear map and so
really the what we have done is a way
that we encode all the air that we
sample and in the end we are able to
evaluate to something that is the
product of the secrets time a public
matrix plus some noise and if you think
in this way that record the goal is to
hide all the secrets and in some sense
to use this digit 50 multi linear map to
do useful applications we must embed
useful information on the secrets so so
theta will give examples it's really the
security so so far have explained the
functionality so record a security so
now I was taught measuring security so
record a security goal is to hide all
the iOW secrets during the evaluation
let's say this is the minimum go roughly
speaking but the reality of whether we
can hide them in general is complicated
it depends on the structure inside or
the s term that we used during the
evaluation so let me explain right now
what the structure inside the S term
look like because previously are sort of
given impression order s terms are just
a random matrix every row has a random
independent value but I mentioned like
to builder useful applications from this
multi linear map we must have put to her
non uniform stuff inside of the exponent
to make it useful so rather let me give
you a small example of how to embed a
useful structure inside the secret temp
and still intuitively it's not super
it's not obviously wrong
so far and this I also explain but
so so from now I will try to use small
examples to explain to you what are the
smaller examples that we can prove that
hiding is is guaranteed by the iOW
assumption and I will also give some
more example to show you that is that
small example hiding s is very unlikely
to be guaranteed by the Assumption or
any other assumption so let me start
with the small first estimate or example
so think about all the secret terms
instead of being or independent or
random by injective some permutation
matrix structure inside it
sorry not permutation matrix structure
into it so think about all the matrix as
like a 2 by 2 matrix MIB tensor in with
the uniform independent random secret
matrix and you can see like in I define
like if you evaluate you will have the
secret product in the end so if the
product in the end goes to or 0
now our say that like the entire
functionality is 0 if there's any block
inside the final product which is
nonzero I will consider the final
product to be nonzero as well so in this
example the example is designed such
that if you evaluate to 0 0 so you will
choose a 0 times d1 0 times 3 to 0 and
in this case you have this matrix times
this matrix and they actually the the
terms cancel out the product is a 0
matrix so the evaluation becomes 0 and
the or the rest you can say at least the
one block is left so the evaluation will
consider them as well so this is just a
toy example to demonstrate one way of
injecting minimally used for structure
the inside the secret terms of digits 15
and it's actually open problem to prove
whether this construction is or the
secret structure or not so right now I'm
gonna give you another tour example to
photo example 2 we can actually prove
who captured proof all the secrets are
hidden by the ginger 250 motolinia map
and let me tell you this proof strategy
so actually I have no idea about music I
come from electronic engineering
background
so on this whiteboard I'm gonna use this
symbol to represent that the chapter of
this public matrix is not used so what
does it mean by that a trapdoor of this
public matrix is not used it means that
you can use it as a real random public
matrix and assuming audibly with this
public matrix is is random so here I
want to mention another attribute
analyzation of decision or w/e so this
is an error w with a normal secret no
more square secret looks like follows we
assume the Eldar base sample is
indistinguishable from a together way
it's uniform random so you can easily
show that if the secret matrix looks
like a permutation matrix censoring with
a uniformly random secret then the
irritably the air doubly problem with
this permutation tensor the secret is
still indistinguishable from random
because it's just a shifting of random
rows
so is this pocket we can start trying to
prove that actually this construction
hides all the secrets and also in all
the secrets inside of the permutation of
the structures
oh yeah it's a very good question
actually I use different colors to
represent a different independent secret
so this two are the same as these two
are different as it's it's important to
clarify so otherwise if all of them are
the same then the proof won't work and
proof won't work so we were first to
trigger or double a permutation notably
on the first two matrices where their
public matrix is grounded so it's safe
they were everyone can use it has a
audibly sample so right now we have like
the preimage sampling of essentially two
independent two random matrix in random
we are going to trigger the gpv preimage
sampling lemma which says so if you are
going to use chapter sampling to sample
the preimage of the uniformly random
matrix then you're fine because there's
actually a way to produce the same bit
distribution without using a chapter of
the chapter of the a matrix and actually
like other premiums are from a Gaussian
distribution this is indeed the discrete
Gaussian so with this pocket we can also
move on so right now in the next step we
are going to turn off the chapter of a
one using the gpv lemma because we have
proven that you're essentially only
sampling the primitive random images so
there's another way of producing sorry
the samples just using a 1 matrix
without a trapdoor and a sample this as
a discrete Gaussian matrix finally
you've added to get the uniform
so then Serrano we have turned the
chapter off for a while matrix so you
can move out again using these two steps
first using permutation RWE and then
using the TPPA Allah - or the chapter
off as we can see right now on the
picture
there's nothing related to the original
UW secrets and this is the way we prove
that all the secrets are hidden so it's
[Music]
what you map to because it doesn't
satisfy any other yeah hospitals so I
guess let me rephrase this so it has
like a nutrition from what we have seen
so that's supposed like so let's give
her like a recap why this proof works
so essentially like all the image we
have do s they are only uniform and
independent and only appear here so if
like one piece of you to appear
somewhere else then your problematic at
least at about at in the list assess
right so I guess by this it's a time to
introduce insecure example because right
now we are very comfortable with this
secure example and the word one is it
the case that the function is actually
trivial so the whole point is later I
will show that even it looks to beauty
as a not to be a way to use it
let me just a reef is a Lewis question
because in the beginning of this example
I actually cheat a little bit because
the toy example too like all the inputs
valence to one because in the end you
essentially we are showing that all of
them the various two random it turns out
order to applications that can build
safely on digital 15 they also have this
feature from the beginning but as they
both find non-trivial way to use it so
right now we are we we are at so it's
now it's the time to show and easy
insecure example so this almost wrap up
with the general security intuition of
digit 15 so how do we secure example
look like so the simplest way I can
think about explaining an insecure
example is to think about so think about
your taking the product of two secrets
where one secret is completely zero so
let's don't worry about a why do we
think about this case but just think
about simplicity so you're trying to
encode a secret which is identically
equal to 0 so the encoding of 0 is very
close to a trapdoor let's see why so to
encode to encode like a doubly sample
where the secret is 0 essentially the 0
times 0 out or the big public matrix
part and if your sample a premium of it
essentially you're sampling a premium
of a small error term so record that the
perimeter of 0 is a 4 chapter so the
perimeter of a small is almost a chapter
and under some cases it can be turned to
a for trapdoor but rather I just want to
convince you that it already make your
life very hard because so suppose you
have a way to compute eight times
something equals to small then because
this a is going to be used as the public
matrix for the next will be simple so
this puts the secret term of the next or
double sample in danger
so at least this gives you a very very
harsh security warning sign that this is
not something safe to do and for the
people who are familiar about the
literature this is the intuition behind
the zero knives intact like the encoding
of zero are usually very dangerous in
order motolinia map candidates and this
is one small example trying to
illustrate that and more explicitly if
you have like a s two term equal to 0 in
this example the evaluation will give
you only the small error term so if the
small error term is small in the end
then actually you can extract this
expression over the integers and once
you have this equation over the integers
there's a lot of things you can do to
attack the candidate so in fact a beauty
and equation over integer instead of mod
Q is behind the intuition of all the
multi linear Maps attack since the force
to work by a tour with tamia so right
now I just want to describe the brief
security intuition later were don't
think I have time but in theory the
slides there's a site about the for
attack so right now I have give like a
two brief example of one to view sort of
give you a secure case one sort of
simple attack case and I want to wrap up
this part of the talk by you know put
this triggered fifteen like idea into
the general framework of latest
applications so in my opinion there are
like three big categories of ways to
build a little lettuce applications the
first way is like we call we can call it
a relative like schemes where you can
think about the role of the Arab a
secret as the secret key for public
encryption for example and it's just a
and where do we put the message you put
the message like a think about you using
the other be simple to mask the message
and the next framework is a door Raghav
and I mean the quintessential example is
the bg+ that everyone caught so the
difference from the first idea is like a
Rana will use the latest chapter as the
sort of the mass secret key and then you
can derive other functional keys or into
the keys and the different public
matrices so really to do 215 gives us a
new way of designing lattice application
the key difference from the two previous
scheme is you also put the message or
the functionality you want to hide into
the doubly secret so intuitively you
know it sounds great but it will make
your security and analysis more
complicated because in the previous two
cases usually the irritably secret is
innocent-looking it's as a random or
small random that's it but right now the
audibly secret you can put a permutation
matrices other stuff inside it so the
analysis becomes more complicated so
can't you get the same ones using the GS
w type encoding like we know how to get
from nodes
yeah so you can always switch between no
no no both ways like that yes there are
applications you can build Ruby gg+
but you can't you don't know how to this
and the other way around
so actually look above sketching is the
one application this is the open problem
number it would be more that we don't
yet know how
this is over problem number lambda more
details about so in the last half-hour I
will try to mention applications I think
I will try to do a truncated version of
it and they try to spend more time on
open problems so so in the application I
would just put the the security
inclusion I mentioned before one secure
example and the one insecure example
into the two applications the first one
is the private constraint pif the other
one is a obfuscation in general so let
me start from private constraint PRF so
so there go of the little maybe the next
15 minutes is try to explain one way to
get a useful application that is
provably secure from a or w/e and it's
also useful like not everyone everything
emanates to random the application is
called private constraint PRF and as you
can see is there's a lot of objectives
and it is big names so let me try to
explain what is a private constraint PRF
in three slides this slide doesn't count
so first let's start from a
pseudo-random function so a
pseudo-random function is a function
that that so you have or across s to a
function you Korea imported get output
you clearly another input again and as
output and the goal is to say that if
you only have or across s to it it's
indistinguishable from a truly random
function you can think about it as a
exponentially large truth table
let me explain constrained so think
about you start from a pseudo-random
function and try to modify the so you
have a sort of a master secret key for
the original PRF and you want to have a
way to derive a constrained key a
modified key that change the
functionality some points doesn't have
to be one point you can change as large
fraction as you want and just think
about the functionality you can change
it and sort of still preserving the
function structure and the most
important what is the last word
privately so you want to change the
functionality and the Zen you are asked
to hand out either the original key or
the change the key the go it so that the
adversary who gets the key cannot tell
whether you get the original key or the
constrained key so think about you have
changed a lot of things they cover it
right three slides so what is the motive
of looking at private constrained PRF
sounds like a complicated notion first
let me give you a very strong motivation
of look at it is if you cannot achieve
two key secure private cost in the PRF
so in the previous example I say your
eyes are given the private modified key
or the original key so right now
stressing the security definition say
you Cask two keys so say maybe like a
two keys one for see what the other
forecaster and see two and so your
either given the to constrain the key or
two other constrain the key so instead
of one you get two so only if you get
two you only need to get two to Institue
to achieve full fledged obfuscation
so let's see why so the obfuscation will
be just the constraint key for the
constraint that circuits the circuit you
are trying to escape and in sort of
preserving or the functionality circuit
like the original circuit in the heart
will compute an input on the function
sorry so original means like you you
give the car stream key not changing any
point functionality
like preserving order like like I think
about Oh 1 or 0 preserving everywhere so
you're given two keys and this is the
obfuscator so how to evaluate so you've
added both key on a same point and you
just compare the evaluation output if
they're the same you know it's a
preserving functionality if they are
different you know this is the
functionality triggered by this you
could see and the constraint hiding
implies that the constraint the modified
point is going to be covered by in some
sense you hide the circuits you want to
obfuscate but I want to mention that we
actually don't know how to prove the two
key security from lwe we only know how
to prove one key security from the other
b-but this is a convenient way to think
about you know why perfect constrained
PRF is useful and so I think yeah I
think at 20 minutes later we'll just say
like office kitchen is basically
constrain the PRF with two keys and you
can take our construction and I think
about is as a candidate all right so if
you only have one key then this also
implies reusable garbo circuits I think
I don't have time to talk about these
applications so the point is like you
know like it has a contract the name
like private constrained PRF you can
already use it to do a lot of things for
example all the applications list on the
board so Brendan let me tell you how to
construct it from lattices this
construction come with three simple
steps so first we want to do as before
like history slides first you want to
start with a lattice space of PRF and
then you want to embed a constraining
into it
third step you want to do step two
privately so let me briefly mention the
ideas behind each of the steps so we
start from a lattice base a PRF which is
the
the parka DeRozan construction and is
then to embed a constraint we need to
have a way to translate all the circuits
into a permutation branching program and
burnt ends theorem shows how to
transform logged up circuit into a
branching program and the final age 15
allows you to cover all the
modifications up and have a security
reduction from your W so let me start
from something that Chris don't have the
time to talk about in the previous talks
about how to do a lattice space appear F
actually I want to do this step slowly
because I have a cute open problem from
this at least I don't know how to solve
it so so how do you use lattice to be
just a PRF without the constraint hiding
so think about you have a lot of you
have to n RW secrets over the mass
square and small you have a public
matrix a and the evaluation of the PRF
is simply taking order subset products
and then run it by a small modulus by
rounding in this stock lock think about
the modulus Q the big model of skew is
super large exponentially large and we
are just going to round it to two by
running to - I mean if like the final
result is smaller than Q over two we
ought to put a zero if the final result
is bigger than Q over the two where we
are to put one and sort of luck we need
Q to be exponentially large because
later we are going to inject a lot of
noise inside it and we are going to
guarantee that the amount of the noise
we inject is always exponentially small
compared to the modulus alright so let's
do it so let me prove to you why this
construction gives a PRF and I'm
connected to proof by example for why
input which is my favorite input 0 1 1 0
I'm going to show that I'm going to show
that this evaluation is random
indistinguishable from random
so let's get started so first I try to
inject an ee noise here and because I
use other small secret terms so adding a
small secret here small noise here the
product together with this is juice more
so I can insert the noise without
changing the functionality and in other
words only changing the functionality
with negligible probability so then
let's trigger audibly on the last block
make it a random sample then let's
inject the noise again and again
unfortunately that's the end of the
slides so we get a random sample for
that equation for that evaluation and I
doing can do it for many inputs so here
is a not open problem but there's the
exercise so we use rounding in the end
so we take subset product and around it
so the first is an exercise that shows
that taking the matrix product without
rounding does not give a pure it's a
exercise so the next question is a I
think at least I don't know how to solve
it so that's why I call it open problem
so prove what this proves that when the
modulus Q that we use like in the middle
of the computation so previously I
mentioned like we use Q as a
exponentially large value so what if we
use Q which is a polynomial and right
now you are free to choose whether the
secret terms are small or large or
uniform or whatever not whatever by the
way like a may be uniform small
uniformly large and the proof or
disproof is that this construction is a
PRF the only difference from the
previous construction is right now the Q
is becoming from a large value to a
polynomial a large value I think this is
a very crude problem to to think about
they known about the in in between like
so financial in NZ we know how to prove
it and for Polly's we don't and what
about in the maybe like super Polly rice
I think so there will be a threshold is
that the proof doesn't work let's take
that as a threshold
I think after proof doesn't work
everything is open I want to make this
as a more explicit open problem by say
accuser polynomial but essentially you
made slightly smaller all right so now
we have complete step 1 let's think
about how to embed a constraint
so so the rich apps question is like so
previously I show a proof that assuming
or w/e and Pitino is no it's not noise
so the question is like if you assume a
OWR with polynomial modulus insecure can
you have a proof not clear I think
so open problem 2.5 like if you can do
it from there
I need to think about it yeah right that
does matter
it's you yeah this will increase I think
I guess yeah thanks for the discussion
let me have a cup of water so let's
continue like how to embed the
constraint into this construction so I
think I'm gonna speed up in that
constraint you need to come convert the
circuit into a permutation matrix
pension program and there's a quick
example of how to convert to indicate
into a major expansion program to think
about you have input wire one two one
two and we took a bearing to serum and
have a with five branch and program as
proof by example zero and a zero you get
one zero in the wire multiplier you get
one well in a zero you get one okay you
get identity matrix and finally only one
and the way you get something which is
no additive matrix so and again you can
extend this to lock that circuit to a
polynomial
so the most important step is the last
step that how to do step two privately
so to do that we're going to embed the
the permutation Bertrand program into
the secret term of the LW sample so
think about it start from the beep PPR
PRF and instead of each matrix as a
uniformly random matrix from small
distribution you think about it as a
permutation matrix tensor ring small
random matrix for example as this and
this then you wrap it up by the digit 15
coding and that's it so the way to wrap
up is like I think about as there's a
lot of intermediate a matrix space relay
to a 1 and a 0 and do the pre meter
sample to sample these two first these
two so each of them represents the
encoding of permutation matrix tethering
the other procedures
and so how to prove that the branching
program is hidden in the digit 15 coding
we're going to apply our small example
lemma that we learned from the last
apart so record a toy example we had
before like all the matrixes permutation
matrices and all the l ee secrets are
independent in each chunk so then we
just apply the same proof technique go
all the way to the left using
permutation audibly and the three PB to
close the trapdoor go all the way from
the right to the left so that you can do
the same thing here and essentially the
goal is to prove the real constraint PRF
with other matrices or the permutation
matrices inside of secret.this
indistinguishable from everything sample
granted like at the first scene without
trapdoor immersing discussion from
just to ask Lewis last question like why
is it useful like officially we are
still doing a PRF so it turns out like
to make it a useful way essentially need
to think about you already published a
lot of outputs by evaluating the PRF on
the original unconstrained the key so
you get a lot of output already so then
you get the constraint key we are going
to prove that the constraint key is
secure even given these a lot of inputs
so then you can compare pairwise so you
can think about this as a way of token
based obfuscation you're not going to be
able to evaluate all the points but
other points you have created before so
you can partially evaluate on a lot of
points
so the takeaway from this perfect
constraint PRF construction is it is
safe to use digit 15 to encode
permutation matrices and make it useful
so I want to give a list of so actually
like doing constraint PRF you don't need
to use digital 15 this is just a one
example you can do from Jeju drifting in
fact like the one from digit 15 it only
works for branching program which is NC
one circuits and as there's a way to do
private constrain PRF for all polynomial
size circuit from essentially the in gg+
technique and I want to rephrase like a
re like rewrite the problem mentioned by
Shweta so or maybe reef is the same so
is there a way to transform like the
digits 15 based application with the
dual rocket based application so in
factor we have one example from Jeju
drifting which is a lockable of
discussion that we don't know how to do
from other 9s based application
framework and I think predicate
encryption we only know how to do it
from bgg plus if you do ggh 15 this is
implementable because it is implemented
on loaded at the end there like a
comparator I mean this branching program
representation it makes things much
worse right because you you take NC 1
and you blow it - poly
sized branching program and then you
degrade the error polynomially at every
step so the parameters are going to be
much much worse so it depends on like
for some program it's natural to
represent a as a pressure program yeah
you managed to do it you'll end up with
a scheme that supports smaller deaf and
has much worse parameters right but the
question is let's say you're willing to
take that pitch yeah so I want to use
the last 10 minutes to go through
obfuscation and over problems so I chose
to do a simple way as I mentioned before
like you can think about obfuscation
it's basically private constrained PRF
with two keys one for the constrained
C and the other one for all one so
actually this is a rather a historical
incorrupt way to view it I must confess
that the historical correct way to view
it is private constrained PRF is almost
like the original of Skater translated
into the digits 15 language and the only
output to one branch so instead of
outputting a functional branch and dummy
branch to compare the output to one
branch energy as a way to prove it is
secure so from this point of view let's
look at her like the digit refitting
based off skater you can think about one
branch which is encoding order no
identity permutation branching program
which represents the functionality the
other branch represents or an entity I'm
gonna skip all the details about the
further Kilian randomization scalars et
cetera et cetera just to want to give
you a security intuition that why is it
first why is it so hard to prove
anything from it and secondly when a
sufficient amount of evaluation of zero
is available will capture a break the
obfuscation screen so first let me
explain the easier one to explain which
is that why the proof strategy doesn't
work now this is exactly captured by the
intuition mentioned by a sweater like a
half an hour ago so when you have two
chains of this digits 15 chain so record
the last matrix are the same like it's
less in this example it's all a 2 so
instead of proving like a one guy as
interesting
random right now you have to correlated
sample this one ended the one on the top
so these are to correlate the random
matrix and we don't know how to come up
with the kind of like an analog of gpv
to handle that that's a kind of the
easiest way to explain why the current
technique of proving anything is right
so that's the next slide came to when a
sufficient amount of evaluation to 0 is
available we can actually break the
office kitchen scheme the simplistic
example I can give is quite complicated
instead let me give you the summary of
the feature of the attack so again let's
record the basic evaluation pattern so
if we have an evaluation which actually
goes too small you have some terms which
are like a noisy small terms and you can
recover the exact terms over the integer
and you can do many things
after you get such an example such a
sample and this is actually my first
founded by the initial attack of Toronto
is actually over Seattle 13 and then we
generalize it to digits 15 so think the
the talk I want to mention now is a
classical polynomial time attack it
works as long as so first let's think
about it this is all 0 functionality in
a second let's think about you know
after you transform a circuit into a
branch and program the input has some
repeated a pattern like it's a input on
bit 1 input a bit to input a bit one
again input a bit water again to again 1
2 1 2 1 2 1 2 let's say this they
actually want to see 4 5 6 8 but let's
say all the input only repeats for
constant times then we have a way to
attack that's the description of the the
final result
also there was an attack right yes so in
fact that I mean just skip to the
summary of the so this is the summary of
the IO status I promised to give at the
beginning of the talk so I'm I can only
say I'm more familiar about all the
candidates derived from the teachers
drifting technique maybe a little bit
more about you deserting so these are
almost like the main works about the
that reflects the granted status of IO
and I think sweater is asking the second
line like you have a quantum attack to a
simple branching program so I think
right now if we take the short summary
if you take the original GG 815 of
station candidate or you take the world
from cvw 18 you make sure that all the
input bits in the branch and program
repeat for super constant time in fact
the first security parameter many times
and you also make sure that we inject a
noise into it you check the super
polynomial and when the noise forget
about the efficiency then there's no
attacks we don't know any other attacks
after you make these two safety measures
what does it depend on it shouldn't
depend on the input tray
so better programmer two repetitions
think about it like the the branchman
program have the input pattern so the
first time put a bit it conscious for
example the first step the third step
the fifth step I want to say if all the
input bits it only controls constant
steps then the cvw attack
[Music]
they do with the more than constant then
it's blows up so is this something you
can usually in short I mean it's better
way to take a generator ranching program
so you can put it with identity matrix
that's the easiest way to to do it
but I'm not sure you can compare it
anymore like you have to and also to
connect it to the talk next week
even if you use a quantum algorithm we
don't know how to break it in fact right
now there's not many quantum and
candidate for IO which is surviving so
at this moment I don't want to say I
believe this is quantumly hard because I
actually have some insights of using
quantum algorithm to do something known
to be right but I don't know how to
actually break it but I think it's a
interesting direction if we have time
and also wants to try quantum algorithm
so some lettuce based constructions so
these stupid
I want they different so how are they
different
so you can think about it's not broken
it's not okay it's not broken by me
maybe someone else has the idea to break
it so I don't put a lot of money on it
but I think it's I think it's very hard
to break so you can think about the VW
construction differ from that so I think
it's fair to say that in general you can
take of them as the dialects of the
original construction of San John a talk
so I think in cbw 18 we introduced two
main difference ways like we make sure
that the scalar you know the scalar
whatever it is and abandon a scalar can
actually be non-cumulative which makes
this part less easy to use and the other
step is we make sure you need muster
repeat for super super custom steps the
parameter mini steps a factor like this
is something to point out because in the
implementation of digital team but also
to assume that you need to repeat but of
course to comparators the first province
all right so I want to use
and Belle's problem because yes
so I think the maybe you refer to the
implementation in the CCS paper yes
that's where they didn't realize you
need to repeat and actually it's a
where to play next I think let me try to
mention the most important ones about
the urban problems the first obvious
urban problems is to handle other things
in the middle that we don't know how to
break we don't know how to improve I
think two promising examples witness
encryption and the general evasive
function of skaters I must escape a very
interesting joke in this talk
so under there I think a very
interesting direction is to you know if
we want to prove anything related to
obfuscation or anything we don't know
how to prove we need a new heart
problems without mark you because
essentially we are gonna get a lot of
encoding which like a small mark you I
want to mention one of the very
interesting attempt it's actually not
from any multi linear map to our
approach but rather from like a bilinear
maps plus doubly plus low degree PRG all
the way to succeed to Fe all the way to
i/o this approach so in the recent work
of brachot or in the genitor they
proposed the following assumption to say
you're given a audibly sample as normal
as we normally did and then we want to
put the error into some other low degree
functionality so think about the queue
as a degree 3 function and it takes
three inputs each of them a vector of
dimension M and you get say the capital
N equals to n to the one point minus one
many of these polynomials so in some
sense you get PRG like stuff which is
low degree in the opera's are small
stuff
it also output sings which doesn't which
are not mod Q so see if you have such
assumption in fact they need a
decisional assumption of it and there's
n plus pi linear map you can go all the
way to I owe these polynomials
I mean you you can knew them as degree
polynomials Oh we'll see you can
equivalently view them as degree two
polynomials over CQ so you are not
actually getting rid of the zq so this
is an it depends on the way you view it
you're saying yes you can rewrite these
things so that it
I mean it's high degree over the years
but its degree 2 / zq you're just doing
variable substitution right it's
substituting me for s4e then you you
still get the grade 3 because you have
to ultimately evaluate it in the
bilinear map we can we can check off
nine but as far as I know / CQ it's
always MQ it's empty multivariate
quadratic but over the Q instead of over
that's the difference alright so
automatically it applies to urban
province the first problem is just to
break it and the open problem number six
is if you cannot break it so compute I
or something else they're actually from
it instead of goes through the rod
so another motivation is efficiency in
fact I want to motivate us to look back
into digit searching and a co2 deserting
from the efficiency perspective because
so I have mentioned that you can build
private constraint prf and Lochaber
obfuscation using the g15 framework I
think you can translate this to
construction in language of teacher
setting and co2 asserting the challenge
is can improve them a concrete
assumption like a variant of untrue or
proximity GCD I believe if this is
doable
it will give new insights on the
security understanding of these two
multilinear maps and also it's very
likely to improve the efficiency in some
sense if comes from PRF is so powerful
if you can make it small and efficient
it's great and the last open problem
again remind everybody this becomes one
more zero after it and also I want to
remind problem number seven seven that's
a that is B script OB on the lattice so
this is the end of the my talk
[Applause]